wer denn jetzt will schickten die grünen
ins rennen ums kanzleramt annalena
baerbock oder robert habeck die beiden
wollen ihre entscheidungen bekannt geben
zwischen ostern und pfingsten ich hab
jetzt schon mal geguckt wer müsste es
denn werden
ich komme am ende zu einem ziemlich
klaren ergebnis die kriterien von
regierungserfahrung bis peinlichkeit
potenzial
ja ich wollte jetzt auch nicht darauf
verzichten auch dahin zu gehen wo es
wirklich wehtut ja auch dahin gehen wo
es wirklich wehtut ins archiv habe ich
ein paar perlen gefunden und in den
bundestag auch da rein will ich euch
mitnehmen weil ich mich gefragt habe was
sagen denn die abgeordneten selbst zum
einen wie von den grünen und auch von
den anderen parteien allein schon die
vorstellung dass sie analysiert werde
oder robert habeck neben joe biden
stehen oder wladimir putin treiben wir
das grauen auf die stellen ja es war
nicht immer nett ich bin da einen
passenden politik reporter fürs zdf wer
geht für die grünen ins rennen ums
kanzleramt dass unsere frage heute was
meint ihr wer wird's was sind auf eure
sich die entscheidenden kriterien lässt
uns teilhaben an euren gedanken schreibt
unten in die kommentare
los gehts kriterium 1
[Musik]
robert habeck wer war sechs jahre lang
landesminister in schleswig holstein für
energie umwelt und landwirtschaft das
ist schon ziemlich das brett sechs jahre
ja gut das war jetzt natürlich nicht
immer die ganz große weltpolitik
es geht um über 1000 euro entschädigung
für bauern deren gäste zu vogelfutter
wird diesen weg will der grüne
landwirtschaftsminister in kiel nicht
mitgeben bietet stattdessen geld wenn
der bauer seinen acker zur kulisse macht
den gänsen das feld also gleich ganz
überlässt das fasten sie alles vergessen
sie alles voll das ist ehrlicher weise
so ja und das ist ehrlicher weise ein
problem aber eher als ehrlicherweise
auch gelöst und nicht nur das ja auch
andere themen es gab zum beispiel den
berühmten muschel frieden gab es ein
riesen knatsch zwischen fischerei und
naturschutz
auch da hat er vermittelt und am ende
alle versöhnt und so gab es eine reihe
von problemen wo er sich ja einen ruf
erarbeitet hat als pragmatischer
problemlöser im vergleich annalena
baerbock fassen wir mal ihre
regierungserfahrungen zusammen fertig
gibt es keine sie hatte kein
regierungsamt in den bisher auf keiner
politischen ebene aber sie sagt ich bin
trotzdem gewappnet für das amt so
zumindest hat sie sind etwa kürzlich der
bild am sonntag gesagt drei jahre als
parteichefin abgeordnete und mutter
kleiner kinder stellen ziemlich und für
alle die gerade im gespräch sind gilt
niemand ist als kanzler vom himmel
gefallen ja das stimmt stimmt alles
trotzdem würde ich sagen kriterium 1
regierungserfahrungen klarer fall für
robert habeck 10
[Musik]
ja weil es ist noch gar nicht so lange
auf der großen politischen bühne
das älteste was ich im archiv gefunden
habe war ein auftritt beim parteitag
2009 in dortmund vor der europawahl
damals interessant warum es damals ging
beziehungsweise worum es nicht ging also
es ging um das europäische politik das
europäische parlament und nicht
irgendeine nationale kanzlerin ja
irgendeine nationale kanzlerin wer
interessiert sich schon für solche
personalfragen im januar 218 sind die
beiden die neue doppelspitze der grünen
geworden an der lena werbung und robert
habeck ende 219 dann wieder gewählt sie
mit einem absoluten rekordergebnis 97,1
prozent
und er mit 90 4 prozent auch nicht
schlecht und das ist schon erstaunlich
bei einer partei die er dafür berühmt
war dass intern die fetzen flogen
er muss so richtig gerockt hat bei den
internen diskussionen wo es ja auch
immer zwei flügel gab hier die fundis
die fundamentalistisch grünen hier die
real los die er wohl realpolitisch grün
und jetzt interessant dass die beiden
habeck und berbalk vom selben flügel
sind von den real los und trotzdem oder
vielleicht auch deswegen ist es ihnen
gelungen die partei hinter sich zu
vereinen ja zu einer großen
geschlossenheit zu führen und um euch
mein gespür für diese geschlossenheit
der grünen zu geben auch dafür wollte
ich euch mit in den bundestag nehmen und
tatsächlich es ist als breit man gegen
eine gummiwand der harmonie wir haben
ein wirklich gutes teamwork wir reden
nämlich nicht nur darüber haben sie die
entscheidung ist schon gefallen
also ich kann niemanden im kopf rein
gucken aber ich bin froh dass die grünen
ein luxusproblem haben wir am 2
wunderbar geeignete kandidatin wenn wir
haben ein luxusproblem wir haben zwei
großartige parteivorsitzende
einer von beiden wird es machen ja
interessant zum teil benutzen sie sogar
dieselben begriffe luxusproblem klingt
fast ein bisschen so als selbst da
interne sprachregelung an die sich alle
halten zumal sich auch wirklich alle in
dieser art hier geäußert haben dass
werden annalena baerbock und robert
habeck alleine entscheiden gemeinsam und
dania parteien vorschlag machen
da gehört die entscheiden das alleine
ist auch interessant hinterzimmer deluxe
hat dessen abgeordneter von den grünen
selbst genannt mit dem ich telefoniert
habe wenn man das aber positiv weil er
sagt am ende profitieren wir gründen
alle
weil die wählerinnen und wähler das
belohnen an der wahlurne im vergleich zu
den anderen zu spd oder cdu zum beispiel
wenn man sieht was die so veranstaltet
haben als sie das letzte mal entweder
ihren vorsitz bestimmt haben
er war mehr in drama als bei einer
durchschnittlichen bachelor staffel
naja die grünen im vergleich dazu der
rosamunde pilcher im endstadium für
journalisten in der media babbel ist das
manchmal so ein bisschen langweilig
zumindest für die darauf aus sind
spitzeleien durchgesteckt zu bekommen da
ist bei den grünen tatsächlich nichts zu
holen insofern kriterium beliebtheit in
der partei angesichts dieser großen
harmonie kann es nur schiedlich
friedlich unentschieden ausgehen 11
damit zwischenstand 2 1 für habeck
[Musik]
ja momentum was ganz wichtiges im
politischen berlin lässt sich gar nicht
so richtig greifen was das konkret
bedeutet ist er so ein gefühl ops grad
verein läuft oder nicht auch da lohnt
sich es noch mal ganz ganz tief
zurückzublicken 2013
annalena baerbock damals mit ihrer
jungfernrede im bundestag heißt
tatsächlich so
und es geht gar nicht so sehr darum was
sie gesagt hat sondern wie sie sagt der
gastgeber polen veranstaltet parallel
eine coole gipfels parallel zur
weltklimakonferenz und sie herr altmaier
verdeutlichten mit ihrer kurzen
stippvisite welche priorität der
klimawandel bei ihnen besitzt da schaut
er ganz gönnerhafte er altmaier auf die
novizin du bist sie gar nicht so
schüchtern wir vielleicht denkt sie
haben die war abends mit maybrit illner
auf dem sofa geplaudert anstatt mit den
chinesen über co2 reduktionsziele
ernsthaft zu diskutieren
inzwischen sitzt übrigens selbst sehr
gern bei maybrit illner oder bei anne
will oder bei maischberger 2009 10 war
annalena baerbock die talkshow-königin
wie media schrieb niemand hat er mehr
auftritte als sie in talkshows abgelöst
hat sie da übrigens robert habeck der
war ein jahr vorher die nummer eins und
das steht so ein bisschen sinnbildlich
dafür dass annalena baerbock im internen
ranking mindestens aufgeholt hat bis
dahin war es so dass robert habeck
eigentlich gesetzt schien als nummer
eins bei den grünen auch bei ziemlich
vielen medien so schrieb der stern er
sei vom auftritt mit dem jungen willy
brandt vergleichbar
der spiegel nannte ihn quasi kanzler und
der focus schrieb über die republik
harbeck
das ist dann eben irgendwann so ein
bisschen gekippt werden wenn man sich
den letzten monaten haben
regierungsviertel unterhalten hat über
dieses thema dann hat man eben immer
häufiger den namen annalena baerbock
gehört wenn es darum ging wer die grünen
ins rennen führen wird
und interessanterweise ist das auch bei
abgeordneten anderer parteien so manche
haben es mir auch in die kamera gesagt
und auch begründet warum also ich glaube
dass es am ende baerbock wird weil die
sich die sachen wenigstens durchliest
weg da macht das spontan alles und das
ist können wir nicht gebrauchen momentan
ich kann mir vorstellen dass das an
allee niewerth weil sich für die sie
viel schlagfertiger ich finde auch dass
sie intelligent charmant zumindest für
eine von beiden
es gibt allerdings auch welche die sagen
es ist insgesamt keine gute idee von den
grünen jemanden ins rennen zu schicken
für die kanzlerkandidatur vielleicht
auch aus eigener erfahrung wir werden
keinen kanzlerkandidaten aufstellen auch
keine kanzlerkandidaten aufstellen und
die grünen sollen sich verheben mit
ihrem anspruch künftig die führende
politische kraft in deutschland zu sagen
guck mal das politbarometer ja da sehen
wir die fdp die braut sich tatsächlich
nicht die frage stellen ob sie einen
kandidaten aufstellen oder nicht bei den
grünen allerdings sieht das wieder
anders aus bei denen sie inzwischen
wieder so aus als ob sie tatsächlich am
ende ins kanzleramt einziehen könnten ja
und interessante zahlen gibt es übrigens
auch was unsere frage betrifft habeck
oder berbalk 28 prozent sagen habe sei
geeignet für den posten des kanzlers 25
prozent sagen berbalk das ist ein
vorsprung noch aber kein großes polster
guck mal was passiert aber ich würde
sagen beim kriterium momentum ganz klar
punkt für annalena baerbock
zwischenstand 2 2
[Musik]
jeder macht mal fehler robert habeck hat
auch schon mal zweimal denselben gemacht
bei twitter drider zuerst vor der
letzten bayern war den bayern
abgesprochen dass sie in einer
demokratie leben fanden die bei der csu
vor allem überhaupt nicht witzig weil
sie gesagt haben bei aller kritik uns
als undemokratisch zu verunglimpfen das
geht ein bisschen weit ja stimmt hat
habe ich dann eingeräumten gesagt sowie
weil die falsche wortwahl um dann wenig
später fast genau dasselbe in thüringen
noch mal zu machen dass viele jetzt noch
schlimmer fanden als die tatsache dass
er eben zweimal in denselben fehler
gemacht hat war der umgang werden jetzt
die reaktion eher zum beispiel derzeit
ein interview gegeben hat da gesagt
twitter hilft nicht ehrlich zu sprechen
sprich twitter war schuld ein böses
twitter hat ein konsequenter weise
darauf gehört und sich fortan auf ein
medium konzentriert das ironie ein viel
weniger oberflächlich ist ja und das
auch raum für komplexe gedanken lässt
insta kleine kostprobe wenn man eine
herde koniks muss ich auch erstmal
wikipedia
das ist eine pony cars aus osteuropa
wenn man also eine herde koniks trifft
und sich still auf den boden legt
schreibt kommen sie manchmal und
schnuppern an einem das ist so dicht an
magie wie man kommen kann
das ist wiederum so dicht an
fremdschämen wie man kommen kann meinte
der spiegel dazu der den eindruck
gewonnen habe sei die tat in seiner
politischen karriere beim zustand
absoluter schmerzfreiheit angelangt
schauen weil im vergleich dazu auf
berbalk die social media mäßig ziemlich
unfallfrei unterwegs gewesen bislang was
ihr manchmal als schwäche ausgelegt wird
dass sie so schnell spricht dass sie
schon mal die ein oder andere silben
verschluckt und zweitens das finde ich
persönlich ein bisschen unfair ihre
stimme dafür kann ja niemand was sie
selbst wisse dass viele menschen ihre
stimme als schrill empfinden hat
kürzlich die stuttgarter zeitung
berichtet und die zeit hat das ganze
kürzlich sogar mal ausführlich
thematisiert auch die ungerechtigkeit
die damit schwingt die gleichen sätze
aus dem mund von robert habeck oder von
annalena baerbock wirklich der gleiche
klang nicht doch ein anderer hallraum
hier der philosophierende welterklärer
da die informierte praktikerin man
möchte den unterschied überhören aber
die konditionierung hört ihn halt doch
der winzer darum geht was gesagt wird da
sein dann wiederum viele
berbalk hat mehr substanz als habe ich
also inhaltlich gibt es keinen großen
unterschied bei den beiden bossen
vielleicht aber keine großen aber viele
sagen berbalk steckt tiefer drin in den
themen
das liegt zum einen an ihren eigenen
auftritten aber zum teil auch an denen
von h weg weil der ist wirklich ein paar
mal mit anlauf ins fettnäpfchen
gesprungen mal wusste nicht so richtig
bescheid bei der pendlerpauschale dann
bei der bafin jüngst wusste nicht so
richtig was erfordern soll mit blick auf
julian assange jetzt kann man sagen dass
es unfair ihm das immer und immer wieder
aus brot zu schmieren
aber es geht ja auch um was uns
kanzleramt insofern kriterium schwächen
und peinlichkeit potenzial insgesamt
punkt für berbalk zwischenstand damit
drei zu zwei für sie und damit kommen
wir schon zum finalen und wohl
wichtigsten kriterium
[Musik]
die grünen waren traditionell immer
schon die frauenpartei
geschlechtergerechtigkeit immer schon
dna immer schon das große thema wenn
frauen die hälfte der gesellschaft sind
sollten sie auch am kabinettstisch
entsprechend vertreten sein und immer
schon standen den grünen männer im
verdacht dem im wege zu stehen
natürlich immer völlig zu unrecht ich
will doch gar nicht auf die frauenquote
verzichten
also ich halte diese debatte für
ziemlich daneben
tja und wie wichtig den grünen das thema
ist das haben sie auch kürzlich noch mal
deutlich gemacht nach den letzten
landtagswahlen
da gibt's nämlich immer so eine
fernsehdebatte danach mit den
generalsekretären der parteien oder den
generalsekretär innen aber es gibt im
moment keine frau in der position bei
den parteien haben die grünen gesagt in
denen nicht mit uns wir schicken dann
unsere erste parlamentarische
geschäftsführerin weil so eine reine
männerrunde geht gar nicht was aber doch
dann mit anderen worten heisst ins
rennen ums kanzleramt müssen sie die
frau schicken weil in dem rennen sind
bislang ja sonst auch nur männer stolz
von der spd und von der union entweder
sie oder laschet aller voraussicht nach
das heißt da muss doch dann berbalk
diejenige sein sonst wird man dem
eigenen anspruch doch gar nicht gerecht
oder wenn wir von der cdu das
hinbekommen sollten uns die grünen auf
hinbekommt und wenn nicht ja als
cdu-politikerin wurde ich nicht darüber
freuen weil sie dann unglaubwürdig
werden na ja in der tat eine partei die
sich als die frauen partei schlechthin
versteht wenn die jetzt mit dem
wichtigsten personalien man nominiert
obwohl es eine frau will dann wird schon
ziemlich schwer sein zu argumentieren
oder gar nicht sagen die grünen
wir haben waren sie nicht viele frauen
in führungspositionen wir haben müssen
den vorstandsposten wir haben bis in den
listen in den beiden parlamenten
wir haben das sind den regierungen wo
wir regieren deswegen hätte ich auch vor
einem männlichen kanzlerkandidaten da
überhaupt keine sorge also ich finde ja
wenn die grünen ihre eigenen rhetorik
ihrem eigenen anspruch den sie immer und
immer wieder formulieren gerecht werden
wollt dann ist das kriterium geschlecht
eigentlich ein totschlagargument
und deswegen gibt es dafür bei uns auch
nicht ein sondern 100 punkte und die
kriegt natürlich die frau
endergebnis damit 100 drei zu zwei für
anna lena da war ich ja am ende dann gar
nicht so knapp zumindest nach unserer
rechnung nicht
was glaubt ihr wer wird am ende und
warum schreibt uns rein in die
kommentare
und gern auch themen anregung themen die
euch interessieren in diesem
superwahljahr themen die wir aufgreifen
können bei insight politics und kleines
ps noch zu dieser folge hier wenn es
dann am ende doch ein mann wird bleibt
mir bei aller unparteilichkeit nur zu
sagen viel glück damit wenn euch inside
politics gefällt das gern aber da hier
noch weitere folgen